Why do I have a feeling this will break soon?
I have been expecting you Otto
Okay Emil come and give me a hand
Emil is like: GET OFF!
Go and get it!
Jackpot!
If you guys haven't subscribed to our channel
Do us a favor and do it now!
You won't regret it!
Come on Miikka
You can do this!
It's all about your spinning Emil
Let's go!
Why do I have a feeling this will break soon?
A bit dangerous!
It is!
In the "Stereotypes 4" video I had a grip like this
So let's see if I can actually play with it
It's better than my normal forehand!
What a shot!
I like this!
Well, it worked for a while!
Fake reverse
What started as a joke
Actually worked quite well!
For this challenge we need to break the ball a bit
I can't believe it takes this many shots for Otto to break a ball...
We got a crack
There we have it!
The crack is getting bigger and bigger!
It's going over the half way
Now it might be a bit of a challenge already
Good training for your reflexes
Now there shouldn't be any normal bounces anymore!
No, there shouldn't!
Okay, the final stage of a broken ball
That's not a ball anymore
Do you think it's going to work?
I don't think so
Me neither!
Actually got the serve on!
Okay I think we are done with this challenge
Leave your ideas for the next challenge episode
in the comments
And hit subscribe so you don't miss it!
Until next time!